This has the correct behavior, but it's a really foolish way to compute the union of two s.
The reason for doing this is to show you the kind of things that can go wrong
if you just cut and paste code you find without understanding it.
We're doing a lot more work than the original union would have been.
Of course, we could have done this as we have it and got the correct result
by replacing res here with just b.
Searching for code is a good starting point often,
but it's rarely a good ending point, and there's a lot of reasons not to do this.
The first is that you might be violating copyrights
or if you're taking code that is done under certain license.
Well, now, that license might impact the code that you're writing and the uses of it.
These are things to be very careful about.
The other reason and the one that I am emphasizing today
is that you're really missing opportunity to learn something new.
One of the best things about looking at other code is that you can learn from it.
And the final reason is that the code that you find might be broken
just because something is on the internet--you've probably learn this already--
not everything that you find on the internet is true and correct.
This does not mean that we shouldn't be searching for code
and trying to find ways people have solved the problem that we want to solve.
But it does mean that we should be more careful with what we find
than just cutting and pasting it into our code.
Let's go back and look at the code that we found
and there are several things in this code that we might not be familiar with
if all you've seen so far is CS101.
The most interesting one is set, and set is used twice
as well as this bar operator between two sets.
We might guess that well that's doing some sort of union operation
because if this does what it should, it is taking the union of two sets
Let's figure out more about what set means
Here's some choices. This is definitely a subjective question.
And I'll suggest that I think two of these are good answers.